with so there's like chord structures
that felt ethereal like the
[Music]
yeah and you hear those all throughout
the film
how's it going man man i'm hanging i'm
hanging how you feeling
i'm feeling good it's good to meet you
it's good to talk to you
yes man we got a lot going on what um
what you feeling what you feeling i'm
feeling i'm feeling good man i'm feeling
grateful
i'm feeling excited about um making a
piece of work and
and sitting on it for a long time and
then there's a time when it gets out
there in the world
it's connecting with people and man
you can say that again the creative
process is such a journey
you ever hear those those folks that say
trust the process
there's some wisdom in that it's a
mystery
you have a vision at the beginning and
then you trudge through
all of the logistics involved with it
all of the writers block that's involved
with it
i i hear that i feel like it's like yeah
there's the part of the process where
you're like
you get you get that first spark and
you're in it and you're connecting
with the director in your writing and
then like you said there's all the
logistical part of it like coming
from outside of the film world it's an
adjustment to like
i'm sort of learning there's this sort
of sandwich element to it where the
beginning of it is more social
and more like what we're used to and
then the middle of it is
revisions and logistics and and
sometimes
can be more isolating and then at the
end you're recording
a band orchestra or whatever and then
then it comes out
it's like the more sort of familiar
social like
humans connecting part of it um
so but this year that part of it or the
latter end of it
has sort of looked completely different
so right
it's been all virtual it's been all this
you know
so it's it's tricky to navigate because
it feels like well
you're getting the same thing in it but
in it
in a different form and how do you
how do you let it feed your soul in the
same way you know
the connectivity with the audience is
the thing that
feeds our soul you know the
the when you release it the response and
the feel that
the feedback loop of that totally get
what you're saying just the aspect of it
being so social just figuring out
two years before you know it was
finished
we were having conversations and when it
was done we were all isolated on zoom
i know it's crazy the whole another
world i i mean i don't know how
how things would have turned out in
terms of the resonance with the public
but i i sure would have liked to feel it
even doing tv
five nights a week and you know sure
yeah years having the audience there
and at home you get both you experience
the audience at home and you meet people
around the world when we go on tour and
they
they feel like they know you but then
the audience that's coming in the house
is different every night
yeah you gotta you gotta you gotta feed
off that and react to that
yeah you're balancing both at once but
with joe it was interesting because
i knew that they were
[Music]
like moments like that i'm talking and
playing but to catch it
in the narrative for it to make sense in
the narrative of the movie
still feel spontaneous yeah
that was such it was it was such a
balance between
uh working with pete the director
the way an actor would he would say how
would joe say this
how would joe play this or um you may be
moments in the script where
my words ended up in the script because
that was the only thing that could
yeah the moment
yeah yeah i was going to ask you that
exact thing like because there's there's
moments when you're talking and playing
at the same time
and it feels like how yeah how how did
you it would have to have come from you
because there's no way to really like
build that in a sort of calculated
um functional way it has to be come from
like a naturalistic feeling like because
music is storytelling so
you're playing and talking it's all it
felt very singular so
what i was wondering if how they like
how
jamie jamie's voice with your playing
how that was so
seamlessly intertwined it makes sense
that you must have just been like
talking and building that character you
know yes it was amazing
to collaborate with pete and also jamie
on making joe who he was
they were like the physical side of it
was one aspect but then
what ended up happening is pete would
ask me to emulate
what joe would say and i would give the
tapes to jamie who
could he can imitate anything yeah yeah
famously yeah literally imitate anything
i know i've seen him do that do do i've
seen him do john legend and i've seen
him
yeah yeah yeah amazing it's like
the character of joe was going through
all of these different
different filters you know they would
film me with cameras
and they would capture his physical
presence but then sometimes they would
record my voice and record me telling
stories or
ask me about my experience in the jazz
scene when i was
a teenager and then that would go to
jamie or that would go to the writers
who were doing the script and
it was really amazing for me to see it
all come together in the end
yeah cause i i it was trenton atticus
and i
working but then there was this
character who i was also
a part of building yeah to see it all
coming yeah oh click yeah that must have
been powerful
and i know i know that feeling like i
had it with
this film too where that i scored where
i'd seen the
dailies every day i'd read the script
right i'd written the music
before they started shooting i've done
all this i knew what was going to happen
in the story
but nothing can really prepare you for
the experience of when it all
clicks it's that that expression the sum
is greater than
i can i always mess up this expression i
think i'll live my whole life and never
get it right the sum is greater than you
know the parts or what you know whatever
it is
but it's that thing that makes it the
hair on your arm stand up you know
there's something that
that happens when it all when it all
comes together you know
that you can't really account for even
if you have even if you were privy to
each stage in the process you know well
man
i that's that that's what i
i really enjoy about your your work it
it feels like everything is coming
together
sequentially and then
the end result is inevitable
but it's not forced last black man in
san francisco i really love that
oh thanks man and uh it's funny um
i mean maybe this is not the phone for
this but i saw an early cut of that film
with no music
oh wow and then to see your music in the
film it really
brought it to life oh wow thanks so much
man that's cool that
that you had that perspective and i got
to see it to see
that was a really that that's one of the
things that actually hit me to your work
which
which was cool because um you rarely get
to see a film unless you're working on
it
yeah without the music yeah yeah
and and um no i feel i i was trying to
create something inevitable with soul
because there were moments we never had
a script trent rezner atticus and i
worked a lot together a lot separately
never on either side did we have a
script
yeah so there were moments where the
music had to carry
it had to be a character and it had to
feel inevitable
yeah um like this is just what would
happen
almost as if you're watching broadway
musical and the person starts singing
and yeah spontaneous spontaneous yeah
it's just there's it's
there's complete fluidity between music
and storytelling it had to be just
come from one source from this the
signal to the
to the other person's soul essentially
exactly
and not and not feel as if there were
all of these
different things at play you know two
worlds within the narrative
this yeah yeah man it just had to all
feel as one
it did yeah and i was going to ask you
about that like how did how did that
work because there's so many scenes
where
where it's almost like the the spiritual
world
and you know and the real world
are seamlessly integrated and the piece
of music
is sort of synthesized and transf
transfused and like flipped on its head
you know as you can see in particular
when
towards the end of the film when joe's
running through the through the
train station and there's a sort of
piece of yours this jazz piece that sort
of
then turns into what what trenton
atticus did
and it did but it's so it's so seamless
like what came first and that and and
and that was a case by case was it seen
by scene how did that
unfold a lot of listening sessions
um to different cues
for instance if it was a cue where it
was
done separate where we all three of us
weren't working together we would listen
and sometimes that would require us
going back and changing
each cue respectively um and then
i have to give credit to ren kleist
who is he did a lot of the sound design
and oh yeah
in the film and this film in particular
not only does the music have a special
role as a character but
man the sound design is is so crucial
yeah it's so crucial yeah because it
makes it tangible makes
it makes something that's that's that
that's imaginative
and and and cosmic feel real and feel
like you're right there in it you know
it's a glue it brings you in i was
always amazed by that with sound like
coming from outside of the film world
like the first time i went up to
skywalker and watched them
mix a film everything you see visually
they have to build
out of nothing sonically and it can be
it can become so visceral like even like
the sound of
like in in minority there was sound of
like the cicadas
cicadas in the in the first scene and
it's like oh
now i feel like i'm in the south i feel
like i'm in
the summer i feel like i'm in this place
i wanted to ask
this as far as the arrangements and
instrumentation is that something that
you had to adjust your approach from
being a musician who plays live
to now um like for instance with soul
there's like chord structures that felt
ethereal like the
yeah and you hear those all throughout
the film there's
instrumentation that matches it's still
jazz but it's not what you would play
if you were playing at the vanguard yeah
yeah but it's still authentic
yeah it's still it's the source is still
there and it's still connected
yeah you know yeah
i feel like i feel like i i had that
experience with
where you where if you're arranging
music for for for a band for rock band
for jazz band
right or you're arranging for an
orchestra
it's all the same stuff it's all the
same you're you're
you're telling a story you're just using
different tools you know you're you're
painting picture using different colors
you know
yeah and i feel like finding which
colors
match which film is always like it's
always a mystery
you can only find it through
experimentation and exploration and
trying stuff out
and then later on you figure out how to
talk about it
pete doctor and i would talk a lot
throughout the process of the film being
constructed in that scene
one of the scenes where he gets into the
zone the audition scene
second one you mentioned was the first
scene to actually be animated with music
for the film
oh wow kind of set the tone of what we
wanted the music
to be in the film and we just had a
conversation
about it several times just of what
should happen in the narrative there but
there was no picture
there was no script it was just the idea
of what
this part of the story should mean and
what it is
play and what it should foretell for his
character art
sure yeah what does it sound like to be
in the zone what does that feel like
yeah i don't like was it and and even
what does it look like
like how would the band in writing the
composition
how would the band drift away once they
see this yeah they they disappear into
the yeah and then you're in your own
space spiritual realm yeah right
and that's so cool reacting real time so
it's almost like
the composition had to have a little bit
of method
acting in it position it's like how do i
write something to a moment that will be
enacted through a character
yeah you know that's crazy yeah but
that's you're shaping the character
you're
you're like co-writer of the film in a
sense because you're shaping
if it's a film about a musician you know
that's the music that's an ex
an expression of his of his soul that's
expression of himself that's
his music is him they're you know
arguably not interchangeable there you
know
and that's kind of what the film is
about is that you're you're not defined
by
i mean such a great message in the film
that like it's
that that what what tripped me out about
the movie
was it was a cool another angle on this
thing that like
made me question like
like made me stop remind you to stop and
and
smell the roses for lack of a better
less cliche thing to say
but remind you to stop and like actually
be present and feel the air on your skin
and feel the the and hear the sounds
around you and not
no what tripped me out about it was like
am i
are we lost souls with our careers with
our music with our this is like his like
our
are we if we're not careful can we
become the
the the uh the stock broker in the film
that that's the law
you know like can where like what makes
us different from that
you know and i think that obsession
the obsession part of it yeah because
it's stupid because it's a religion it's
a
it's obsession it's it's it's it's a
drug to all of us it's all those
things so like how do you how do you
push back from that and how do you like
not become you know not lose yourself in
it in a in a dark way
you know i think that's what was that's
why i didn't
i didn't see this i didn't see that
coming when i watched the movie like it
hit me in a way that
i hadn't really seen that exact thing
explored in that way because usually
the messages follow your dreams you know
all that like believe in yourself
lose yourself in your work and this film
was that but it
but it wasn't really at the end it was
something else too that was more
interesting to me
you know than the thing that you always
see over and over in hollywood
what was your relationship with with lee
when
did did y'all have those kind of
philosophical
conversations and that because there's
such a sense of place like you're
talking about the south you're talking
about the 80s it's just
how did you get there yeah you know what
i mean
yeah well it was different because this
film
you know the score was all not
non-diegetic it was all like
it wasn't like it didn't have to
stylistically be
like uh like the characters in the film
weren't hearing this music you know
it was sort of our conversations were
more spiritually about like
does the music spiritually connect to
the story is the music emotionally
connected to the story
not like does it sound like the south
does it sound like the 80s does it sound
like
korean music does it sound like american
music you know right this film is like
it's a deeply american film but it's
korean american characters
and it takes place in the 80s so the
score had to be
this he didn't want the score to be
korean
sounding he didn't want it to be
american it's counting with like twangy
guitars and harmonicas and
right he didn't want to be 80s synth
it could be none of those three things
but it had to be all three of those same
things
at the same time and that you know so it
was like a form of impressionism
it's exactly you see it it's narrative
impressionism where you're taking
an idea of a thing but it's not actually
the thing itself
exactly nation of those elements makes a
new
thing that's the idea exactly amazing
but with soul
it's it's it's um
it's it's a you're you're doing both
because you have
you can't throw up a random piece of
music over a random scene because
the music is the scene they are like the
music
he's literally has to play and those i
guess imagine those are your hands that
are being
animated oh yeah there was 80 gopro
cameras surrounded
whoa did you put them on your like
did were they attached to your arms or
your fingers at all or just
how'd that work they were attached to
the pianos
beneath above behind
wow those are some bright lights yeah
how do you how do you
play how do you like get into talking
about get in the zone how do you do that
with
litter with like how do you how do you
shut that out
you know i started on tv when i was in
my 20s mid 20s
um so it was just out of
out of college i've been on the road
touring doing a lot of stuff and then tv
was like oh
we have to hit our marks worry about
playing this but not
with the lyrics because of the sponsors
uh then i have to come right back in and
i'm a part of a comedy bit
or i have to change my mindset because
i'm playing with
a guest band or i'm arranging this piece
and i have to also speak to people who
are producers in in-ear monitors
wow yeah it's a lot of hats
that aspect of performing
you know pretty early in my development
no not 33 just to kind of
have that help me in this situation
weirdly because
now i'm in the studio and the cameras
are almost not a thing
sure yeah from the beginning they were
really a thing it was like
what is this this is really tough to
kind of yeah how do you get in
how do you find it you know that's
impressive so with me
it was such a small story in a sense
that it was just five characters in a
mobile home
most of the film so where would
where the music was gonna live and when
it was gonna be big and sweeping was
like
was always a question and like you
really don't wanna it was important for
us that we didn't
over play our hand there you know
because it's like i only we recorded an
orchestra for
for me but we really only used it
in three or four spots really we when we
used like
40 strings or something most of it was
just my
the piano and my voice and a few other
elements right
but then you want to use those big use
the big orchestra
you want to use that sparingly because
for this film i mean every film is
different you know that's the beauty of
it
way man that's there's no right way
you know the late great skeleton love to
write music
in hotel lobbies and bar rooms when they
were on the way to uh
you know the closing time and when
they're cleaning up because
amazing wanted atmospheric sounds in the
background and wanted people to be there
to kind of
play off you know even if you're not
listening yeah
consciously hearing it you'll be playing
something
and then and he sees they oh they perk
up when i do this or that
yeah it's it's amazing just thinking of
the different
approaches you just got me thinking
about that there's no right way
creativity is about whatever is
inevitable
yeah it reminds me of that thing though
that that i think it was a george
harrison thing where like
you know he went he went to study with
ravi shankar and he was
getting into his eastern music and then
through studying with him
ravi shankar told him that essentially
the
the the most eastern way to think about
it or the most
pure way to think about it was act was
to actually go back to rock and roll
because because that was his roots and
that was his soul that was one of his
five that was his
five things you know yes yes i
love that era of george harrison and
even going through uh
i think someone like picasso or miles
davis who
just people who continue to reinvent
themselves yeah you see as you said
the essence of it what's at the center
of it
is always the same yeah it's a concert
that the creativity comes in how do i
take
what i have how does it evolve
over time how does it connect with the
world around me in different ways how
does it connect with other musicians
other people
yeah and how does that blossom that how
do you let
that into your work how do you let that
how do you absorb that and then have it
kind of come through like as your output
in a way that still feels like you yeah
you know i think that's what's tricky
about this year too
us being not experiencing in the same
way as being in isolation
how do you write when you're when your
experiences are
when you're you're you're connecting and
out in the world in in a
you're not experiencing that so how do
you where does it come from
you can find it in virtual ways you know
like i even in this conversation right
now i found
this matisse thing and all these other
things we're sharing these stories and
these
things you can get it virtually but
there's
you know and it's it's a kind of a
learning process but
yeah i do miss i do miss the like going
out seeing live music
playing with other musicians more
regularly having your world sort of
expand that way
is something that i'm looking forward to
you know in the future we got a link
after this man it'd be great
i think you got to do some amazing stuff
i'm all for it man i would love that
man i don't know what but i could feel
it you know
that's that's the beauty of it if we
knew what it wouldn't be as fun
right half the fun is
finding out what that what that would be
you know i think that's that's the
exciting part of this like
and with filming or making or
collaborating with other artists in
general it's like you
you didn't know when you got this
this job with seoul what joe's music was
gonna sound like you didn't know
how that was gonna interact and dance
with jamie's thing and with trenton
atticus's thing
like you didn't know how it was all
gonna come together like like you know
and if you did it wouldn't be as fun
you wouldn't you know like how could you
you know you have to
find it it's not even about i don't ever
want to know
yeah i think the the fun is in
being lost and realizing that there's
again there's no right way to find
yourself but when you
you find it it's like what herbie was
saying man herbie who
we also he worked on this project he was
a consultant
oh wow i didn't know that with herbie
yeah herbie is
is uh one of the things he said early on
when we were talking
is um he was talking about actually
playing with miles davis and he played
like a card
and it had a note in it and it wasn't
the note that was actually in the call
the chord it was like oh it's another
and it was it right in the middle of
miles solo
oh wow and miles was playing and at
some point miles stopped heard the court
he had his eyes closed the entire time
herbie says and then he puts the horn
back to his mouth
and starts playing off of
the note that herbie played by mistake
yeah yeah
he found it it became and it became
he kept playing it and that's amazing
the right note
he was like man that really changed my
whole musical
concept from that wow yeah you see
just just as just that that changed
herbie's musical concept from that yeah
to think that there are no
no no actually together no absolutely
yeah wow that's cool that's an amazing
story
that that he found the one
that wasn't right and that was the one
that he was drawn to
it's like i mean you can apply that to
your life and just
find the thing that the the thing that
hit you in a way that you didn't see
coming and and and don't shy from it
like lean in and
go you know yeah go for it i think
i i i know i'd be honored to to hang out
in person and make something
be awesome yeah man i'd love that man i
look forward to
should be so great talking to you man i
look forward to to getting together and
making something and
and celebrating this moment face-to-face
yeah
yeah man let's get it
you